another restriction on women in
Afghanistan this time they're being told
to stay away from work that's crucial to
getting humanitarian Aid to millions of
people
the talban government is warning
non-governmental organizations that
employ them risk losing their license to
operate in the country
in a society like Afghanistan where for
the past 20 years they have put so much
effort on Afghan women
they were educated and they served
Society these women have supported their
families it is horrible for me to think
that me and my generation are forced to
experience such a situation
the UN the U.S and the EU say they are
deeply concerned eight agencies that
have a significant presence in the
country are calling it a major blow
participation of women in humanity in
action is a fundamental principle which
cannot be bridged it's a principle of
operational independence of humanitarian
action if we need to assess the needs
for humanitarian Aid distribution in a
village uh be it winterization item warm
blanket food or anything they need to
make sure that women participate in
their system in the assessment that's
the first step and the second we need to
make sure that women are there to
deliver the aid directly to women and if
this is not possible then delivery of
that Aid will not be possible the talban
has issued several degrees after seizing
control of the country following the
withdrawal of the U.S forces last year
earlier this week it brought female
students from enrolling into
universities in response male students
walked out of classrooms and women
walked onto the streets to protest
gender apartheid is happening in
Afghanistan the Taliban are totally
erasing Afghan woman from a society from
public eye and for from uh human life
and it's very disheartening because it's
going to affect us in long term and in
short term
structural violence is happening in
Afghanistan we are going toward a very
dark future
after it took power in Afghanistan the
talban promised women fundamental rights
but a year on it systematically
excluding them from public life
Sharif Al Jazeera